now we are ready to boot the genome
assembly problem into the language of
computer scientists let's try to
formalize this problem so the genome
sequencing problem input is a collection
of string output is a string genome
constructed from grid is it a well
formalized problem less espavo because
last time remember in the replication
chapter I criticized Pavel for not
giving a well-defined problem now let's
ask him well this is not a computational
problem ok so allows me to first define
what is k-mer composition of a string
given a string a camel composition of a
string is a set of all camels in that
string so we can order the camels in
this order according to the positions
where they appears in the genome but
please note that the position
information is not available so a more
correct way to order these cameras is
lexicographic order like in the
dictionary so the string the
construction problem input is a
collection of camera output a genome
such that the chemical composition of
the genome is equal to the collection of
Kemmer so we have a well-defined problem
and what is next is to build up
intuitions and algorithm to solve this
problem what is the most nation way to
solve this well let's start with taa and
assume that this is the first three
months of the genome if taa is the first
Kaymer of the genome then what is the
second camera the second camera should
start with a a there's one camera
starting with a a
that is a 80 then what is the next k-mer
the next k-mer should start with 80 here
we have 380 but they are all ATG so we
choose one what is the next k-mer the
next k-mer should start with T G here we
have three cameras starting with T G
which one would you choose
I don't know let's pick a random one
okay so the next k-mer should start with
GT here we have one came out starting
with GT and the next one TT so the next
k-mer should start with with TT but in
our collection
there's no chemists arting with TT well
then certainly there is a need to
develop new algorithms for solving the
problem